my memory that I always look back on
Herrick was my we had to go pick up five
guys who'd been killed at four Benjamin
actually which was up the Elm Valley and
five guys have been hitting one one go
and I remember the the stretchers coming
over the ramp and um
so I'm gonna get emotional um they were
all covered in Flags so there was a
rifles flying on one of the bodies
um a Union Jack on one
um a Welsh flag on one of them and each
body had a different flag on it and then
they were the guys set the the stretches
down and and touched the bodies and went
back off into the fight and there's
nothing you can say to those guys that's
gonna make that better
I'm not brothership like that
Brotherhood it was so apparent and there
are phases as they set their mates dying
on the floor and said goodbye for the
last time and you know that's something
that that Brotherhood is just in your
blood forever
sorry